Speaker 1: Now, the other amazing thing that
happened yesterday is the Mitch McConnell clip
we looked at earlier, where Mitch McConnell
said January 6th was a violent insurrection.
It was a response to House Minority Leader
Republican Kevin McCarthy being asked
about January 6th and saying that there was
legitimate political discourse there. This is
I want to make sure you understand sort
of the parallel of what's going on here.
Rachel Scott, who is the congressional
correspondent for ABC News,
asked Kevin McCarthy about whether there was
legitimate political discourse on January 6th,
and McCarthy seemed to be saying that there
was. OK, so here's the original clip. Here's
the original clip from yesterday morning.
Speaker 2: If there was legitimate
political discourse on Jan. six,
Unidentified: and everybody knows that
was the man who broke inside.
Speaker 1:
OK, so, he says when asked, was there legitimate
political discourse on January 6th? He says, Yeah,
everybody, everybody thinks there was. Um. And
he seems to say even the people who broke in.
He later put out a statement saying, No, no,
no, no, no. The people who broke in were not
engaging in legitimate political discourse. That
is what then led Mitch McConnell to be asked.
This is what Kevin McCarthy said. What do you
think? And McConnell said it was a violent
insurrection. Then this goes nuclear and it goes
beyond parody. Later in the day, Rachel Scott goes
back to Kevin McCarthy to try to ask again, Did
you really mean that the rioters were engaging in
legitimate political discourse on January 6th? And
McCarthy literally runs away when we say Rachel
Scott caught up with him? We're not using the term
metaphorically. She literally ran and caught up
with him. So I'm going to play this. I understand
if you're just listening today, the visual element
is a big piece of it, but McCarthy comes around
the corner. This guy hasn't run this fast since
he had to run away from the rioters on January
six. Comes around the corner at at a gallop,
and then Rachel Scott tries to talk to him, and
he just says it's not good to answer questions
in hallways. You guys understand this. Hallways
acoustically are terrible for answering questions.
You really want to be answering questions in the
bathroom. That's where questions should be asked
and answered. Look at this question, are you going
to make an appointment? It's not going to be good
looking at this guy. He just takes that corner.
You know, if this are a motorcycle race,
he probably would have lost traction coming
around that corner. It's it's not good to answer
questions in the hallway and telling Rachel
Scott to make an appointment. She did. And so
far she attempted to make an appointment, and so
far it has not been granted McCarthy. He is the
prototypical epitome of the politician with no
redeeming qualities whatsoever on policy. He's
a disaster on optics and his relationship with
the media. He's a disaster on having any kind of
actual sort of like guiding principles as an
individual. Ethical principles, moral principles,
completely and totally vapid. And just the
epitome of the gross DC politician. And here,
turning the corner and running away a very bad day
for Kevin McCarthy, starting by saying the rioters
were engaging in legitimate political discourse,
then everything going haywire. McConnell turning
around and saying legitimate political discourse.
It was an insurrection, guys. That's what it was.
Just not going super well for Kevin McCarthy.
And what you have to understand is that this is
not really a departure from how most of these
people operate. They clearly have private,
sincerely held beliefs about what happened on
January 6th, and I continue to believe most of
their beliefs about what happened on January six
are that Trump caused it and it was terrible and
it was disgusting. I genuinely think most of them
believe that maybe Marjorie Taylor Greene doesn't,
you know, maybe Lauren Boebert doesn't,
or Madison Cawthorn. Maybe they liked it.
But most of these Republicans know Trump incited
it, and it was objectively a disaster for the
Republican Party. Even a lot of the media people
know it. Hannity, we know from the texts Sean
Hannity knew it was a disaster, but publicly
he had to put a different spin on it. But
publicly, they continue, some to struggle, some
not to seem to struggle and just say it was all
fine and it was peaceful and all those different
stuff. And for as long as they continue that,
it reinforces this idea that they have no actual
concern with anything other than self-preservation
for their own seats and self-preservation for the
Republican Party. That's all they care about at
the end of the day. If you're if you're listening
today and you didn't see the clips I played,
including Kevin McCarthy running away,
we'll have them on our Instagram.
You can find us at David Pakman show on Instagram.
See the clips. Let me know what you think.